Est-ce que vous avez été sage ?
Oui.
Hé bien, bravo !
Et c'est tout ?
Oui. En fait, j'ai pas de cadeau parce que... parce que...
Tout le monde a été très sage cette année. C'est pas facile.
En plus, le fait que... Je m'y suis pris un petit peu tard...
Du coup j’distribue des p’tits « bravo ».
Ok.
Bah merci...
Et bah bravo.
D’accord.
J’vous ai dit « bravo », au fait ?
Oui.
Est-ce que vous avez été sage ?
Euh… Oui.
J’ai pas de cadeaux...
Vous êtes sûr que vous m’avez bien envoyé votre petite liste ?
Ouais, je vous ai fait un mail.
Alors c’est impossible parce que je lis tous mes mails.
Ah! Regardez dans vos spams, peut-être…
Mes spams ?
Ouais.
Mes spams... Ouais, dans vos spams.
C’est vous: « Rejoins tout de suite une petite coquine dans ta région » ?
Non.
Et bien dans ce…
J’ai un petit truc à faire, en fait...
D’accord ?
Mais…
Non, non, non. Toi, tu restes avec lui.
Et mes cadeaux ?
!Est-ce que vous avez été sages ?
Non mais j’y crois pas à tous vos trucs, là... La magie de Noël et tout ça.
Quoi ?
C’est la magie du « marketing » plutôt, non ? Ça sert juste à vendre des produits, Noël, non ? On est d’accord ?
Mais pas du tout ! Ah ouais ?
Des produits ? Nous ? Oui.
Non ! On vend pas des produits, nous ! Ah bon ?
On vend des services.
Des assurances habitations plus exactement.
Et en ce moment, il y a -30% pendant toute la période de fêtes !
Ah, des assurances habitations ?
Exactement.
Ah bah ouais ! Je suis chaud pour en souscrire une, alors ! C’est vrai ?
Non.
Allez, barrez-vous ! Allez !
Est-ce que vous avez été sage ?
Euh oui.
Et bien dans ce cas, tenez !
Alors...
Premièrement, vous êtes sensés le savoir, je vais pas vous l’apprendre...
Les cadeaux, ça se place SOUS le sapin...
Et ça ne se jette pas comme vous venez de le faire à l’instant.
Deuxièmement, vous êtes censés arriver par la cheminée...
Qui est juste là... Et pas par la chambre. C’est quoi ? C’est une chambre là, derrière vous.
Ça n’a pas de sens, ça.
Et pour finir, on est le 27 décembre.
Vous avez 2 jours de retard sur la livraison.
Bah en fait, on…
Michel Rouji !
Agent de l’inspection du travail.
Merde !
Il est en règle, là, le petit lutin avec vous ?
Faites voir son contrat !
Il est parti, là.
Je le connais pas, je l'ai jamais...
Il est parti. Vous le connaissez pas ? Vous êtes arrivés à 2 ?
Je suis arrivé tout seul.
C’est quoi son nom ?
Lutin.
Mais il y en a plein des lutins ! Comment je fais pour…
Allez, bonne journée.
Est-ce que vous avez été sage ?
Euh oui.
Et il me semble que vous aussi.
Du coup...
J’ai ça pour vous.
Quoi ?
Mais c’est la première fois qu’on m’offre un cadeau.
On m’offre jamais rien à moi.
En fait c’est le cadeau que vous m’avez emmené l’année précédente.
Je l'aime pas en fait. C’est... C'est de la merde, je l'aime pas.
Voilà. Donc joyeux Noël...
Moi, j’ai rien ?
Vous avez été sage, vous aussi ?
J’ai ça pour vous.
Allez, cassez-vous là !
Est-ce que vous avez été sage ?
Euh oui.
Attendez mais… Vous avez pas été créé par Coca, vous ?
J’étais sous contrat avec eux mais ça, c’était il y a longtemps.
Maintenant c’est fini.
Je peux boire ce que je veux.
Et le Pepsi, c’est vachement bon, en fait !
D’accord... Donc vous êtes sous contrat avec Pepsi, c’est ça ?
Euh oui, vous m’avez appelé ?
Non, oubliez-moi.
Cool.
Encore plus de blé !
Est-ce que vous avez été sage ?
Euh oui.
Et vous fêtez Noël tout seul ?
Oui.
Je suis orphelin, en fait.
J’ai jamais eu la chance de connaître mes parents... Attendez...
Attendez, faites voir votre avant-bras, là ?
De quoi ? Là, là...
Le bras droit, là !
Ça ?
C’est une tâche de naissance ? Oui, c’est une tâche de naissance que j’ai toujours eu, oui.
Papa ?
C’est toi ?
Ouais, c’est moi. A l’année prochaine. Salut !
Papa !